die ganze welt hat gerade angst alles
fragt sich was twitter der us-präsident
als nächstes kommt es vielleicht sogar
zum blitztrip man weiß es ja unglaublich
wie weit menschen gehen um von einer
pornodarstellerin abzulenken
kriegsdrohungen zwischen russland und
den usa sind denn alle nur noch irre
und wie geht es jetzt weiter wir gucken
uns die situation sehr ernsthaft an mal
sehen was passiert leute lasst euch
überraschen fuchs wer weiß was ich
morgen mache ich weiß es selber nicht ja
angela merkel unsere kanzlerin sagt
deutschland beteiligt sich ausdrücklich
nicht militärisch in syrien sehr
vernünftig andererseits meine krieg ohne
deutsche das fühlt sich auch irgendwie
falsch an oder ich mal
anyway anyway die merkel hat natürlich
auch ganz andere sorgen aktuell die
musste diese woche erstmal für frieden
im eigenen kabinett sorgen bei der
klausurtagung auf schloss meseberg will
sie nach vier wochen dauert nach vier
wochen dauert zu wollen sie es plötzlich
ernsthaft mit politik versuchen jetzt
geht's los die neue große rückt endlich
zusammen auf den ersten blick scheint
das mit dem zusammenrücken und sich
näher kommen noch nicht so richtig zu
klappen
direkt neben die kanzlerin will sich
einfach keiner setzen
irgendwann steht sie sogar auf und holt
sich höchstpersönlich von draußen einen
tischnachbarn rein scholz müssen eben
merkel sitzen
ja eine solche berichte sind natürlich
auch immer ein hilferuf
es gab halt nichts zu berichten ich
dachte ich hatte gehofft dass die groko
wenigstens eine prioritätenliste
hinkriegt auf schloss schreckenstein
aber nicht mal dass der streit der
letzten wochen beweist eindeutig diese
regierung ist von anfang an nur im
wahlkampfmodus jeder für sich wie auch
ein pavian hügel
apropos pavian haben sie das hier
gesehen horst seehofer beim gruppenfoto
achtung trotz der minister will durch
der heimat minister auch zoho abbauen
würde ich verfasse ich nach heiko heike
eingelaufen beim waschen oder post
so wird das jetzt weitergehen ich
behaupte so wird das weitergehen weil
union und spd sich in einer großen neu
erfinden wollen was gar nicht geht
jeweils nicht wenn man nebenbei auch
noch regieren möchte wie war das denn da
in meseberg die habe ich mir das
vorzustellen
das ist wie wenn man nach den
sommerferien die schule wechseln und
eine neue klasse kommt dass man sich
auch erst einmal finden muss
kennenlernen muss genau
die infantilisierung von politik
schreitet unaufhaltsam voran
was ich aber toll fand jeder einzelne
klausurteilnehmer hat am schluss als
andenken sein eigenes meseberg fotobuch
gekriegt mit allen highlight hier zb die
essensausgabe durch die herbergsmutter
hagebuttentee und dosenravioli das war
das 6h zimmer der ministerinnen kleiner
aufreger alkomat hatte sich heimlich zu
den mädels geschnitten
der schlingel abends dann natürlich
flaschendrehen auf wen die flasche zeigt
der muss den familiennachzug zustimmen
aber sonst war es wirklich sehr
harmonisch nur jens spahn wurde
vorzeitig von seinen eltern abgeholt
weil er ja ja weil er schon wieder ins
bett getwittert hatten das passiert ihm
öfter
passiert in meiner ersten
chronisch bringen hanni und nanni im
gros internat übrigens demnächst als
serie im kicker und von wegen ein weiter
so darf es nicht geben alles geht so
weiter ich sage nur diese ja da sagt die
merkel in meseberg hardware nachrüstung
möchte sie der autoindustrie jetzt
lieber doch nicht zumuten weil das wäre
ja teuer aber was denn dann blaue
plakette fahrverbote was aber wir werden
nach wie vor gibt es auch einigkeit
zwischen umweltministerin und
verkehrsminister eben nicht auf
fahrverbote und blaue plakette setzen
sondern auf individuelle maßnahmen die
einfach auch die bürgerinnen und bürger
so weit wie möglich von auswirkungen und
von auswirkungen denn wir stammen
hatte sich bei seehofer angesteckt oder
was individuelle maßnahmen das heißt
natürlich jeder diese kunde zeit
individuell selber und dann hat sie noch
ganz stolz verkündete in meseberg dass
ich jetzt vier minister gleich vier um
den kohleausstieg kümmern
ganz kurz nachdem die groko ihre
klimaziele für 2020 aufgegeben hat das
nennt man glaube ich zynismus